los feminicidios un problema Sin Control
ni responsabilidad en México este
miércoles familiares de víctimas se
manifestaron luego de que el gobierno
cancelar una disculpa pública por
deficiencias en las investigaciones
cance
[Música]
lación peto a la palabra del fiscal a la
palabra de las propias víctimas que está
en el día de hoy Pero además una falta
de respeto al duelo de estas familias y
a la lucha que ellas dignamente están
realizando para exigir lo que es su
derecho las indagaciones de los
asesinatos de mujeres han estado en el
ojo de las críticas de activistas
según los datos suministrados por el
secretariado ejecutivo del Sistema
Nacional de seguridad pública de los
2.847 asesinatos de mujeres que se han
registrado en los primeros 10 meses del
año solamente
711 fueron contados como feminicidios
mientras los 2.136 restantes Fueron
calificados por la fiscalías como
homicidios dolosos
la rotulación de feminicidio conlleva
una pena más severa para los autores y
obliga a activar protocolos especiales
que abren un abanico de variables más
amplio que un homicidio convencional en
2021 México batió un récord histórico de
feminicidios al registrar 40002 casos
mientras que en los últimos 15 años las
muertes de mujeres aumentaron un 208%